peter piper picked a peck of pickled
peppers a peck of pickled peppers peter
pankau ah pika last one last one it's
gonna be tough bells this is a tough one
it's a balance between being slow and
correct and fast oh yeah
okay here we go three two one go peter
piper picked a pack of pickled peppers a
peck of pickled peppers peter piper
picked if peter piper picked a peck of
pickled peppers where's the peck of
pickled peppers peter piper picked
wow 10 57 10 57 there's no chance
i don't think a scotsman has ever even
said this like i couldn't even
speak let's try it here we go all right
kevin said johnny you're ready three two
one go peter piper picked a pack of
pickled peppers a pack of pickled
peppers peter piper picked a peter piper
picked a pack of pickled peppers where
the peck
you said where
this wears
come on
come on no he's quite right he's all
right you've got two more girls
johnny three that was a winning one that
would have been that would have won
three two
peter piper picked a pack of pickled
peppers a pack of pickled peppers peter
piper picked if peter piper picked a
pack of pickled peppers where's the
pekka pickle
oh jesus he's gone
[Music]
all through the night you're shining
bright i'm your oyster baby you're my
pearl